oh say can't you no I said can't again
I'm really feeling it this American
thing I'm Canadian guys you gotta give
me some slack here a do a crazy dance it
may take a little it may take a lot why
not why not hey guys I'm Abbey shark
welcome to Abbey's kitchens here in
North America we love to celebrate our
great countries also just kind of like
to have a day off where we can drink
here is that are in a pool all day but
today I wanted to share with you some
really tasty bars that whether you're
celebrating Canada Day or the fourth of
July you are absolutely going to love
these are vegan they're gluten free and
they are super patriotic so let's get to
this let's make my patriotic oat bars
football I add some gluten free rolled
oats almond flour oat flour maple syrup
ground cinnamon almond butter melted
coconut oil and a pinch of salt and I
give that a really good stir until it
all comes together
then I pack it really tight into a
baking sheet lined with some parchment
paper
and I set the dish aside to make the
streusel I add some gluten-free rolled
oats almond flour oat flour ground
cinnamon ground flax seeds melted
coconut oil maple syrup a pinch of salt
and some sliced almonds to a bowl and I
give that a good stir finally for my
glaze I mixed together some powdered
sugar and vanilla with some unsweetened
on milk and stir it all together until
it gets nice and fluid
now it's time to assemble for my
Canadian oat bars I add a generous layer
of fresh strawberries top it off with
some powdered sugar and a little bit of
lemon juice and then top the whole thing
off with our streusel
my American friends I mixed a lot of
blueberries and some strawberries
add a little more of that powdered sugar
and fresh lemon juice and then top it
off with our streusel
[Music]
then I put them both in the oven at 375
degrees for about 35 to 40 minutes until
golden brown top them both off with a
drizzle of our sweet glaze and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
berroco mmm well guys I hope you enjoyed
these delicious patriotic oat bars if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with what
you're gonna be celebrating your kanaday
or fourth of July whip subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]